-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy- and Golden Globe-nominated
actress for her role
as Piper Chapman
on Netflix's
"Orange is the New Black."
You can see her next in the
anthology series "Monsterland"
premiering October 2nd on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Now, I am going to get
a white dove orchid,
and I'm going to keep that bitch
alive, so help me God.
-Okay, gauntlet thrown.
-And I'm gonna
finish the scrapbook
in time for Heather's
bat mitzvah. What else?
-Yes, ma'am.
-What else?
Oh, I was thinking,
maybe I could kill Barb.
I slash we.
-Barb Bresler?
-No, Streisand.
Yes, Barb Bresler,
wicked witch of the cul-de-sac.
-Murder Barb?
-Or maybe just her dog.
You know, I'd settle
for her little dog.
Susan.
-Susan.
-Do you know that thing has
10,000 followers on Instagram?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Taylor Schilling.
Hello, Taylor.
It's so good to see you.
-Seth, it's so nice to see you.
How are you?
-I'm hanging in there.
How about you?
-Are ya?
Well, I feel better
now that I'm with you,
and I put on this fancy shirt.
-It's such a fancy shirt.
You know, there's always a fear
that people aren't gonna take it
seriously because they're
Zooming, and look at you.
-No, I took it -- I haven't --
This is the most fancy
I've been in seven months.
I thought it was appropriate
to dress for Seth.
-And you really have,
and I feel like that plant,
that's obviously
an A-plus plant.
I don't want to overlook that.
-I cleared a surface.
-It's just -- The whole thing
is just stunning, as always.
-Isn't it a beautiful color?
-So thank you for being here.
-Thank you. Thank you so much.
-How are you?
These are rough times
for everybody.
Have you discovered
any new coping mechanisms?
-You know, Seth,
I think I've become
like a bit of
a narcoleptic person.
-Oh, interesting.
-Like, I hear, like,
"Oh, plague and pestilence."
And then I go...
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, I pass out again.
-Like, I just sleep,
or I'll fall asleep in different
areas, in new places.
It's uncomfortable.
-That's interesting.
So you just think you have,
like, an internal kill switch
that is just trying
to help you opt out of
the more stressful moments
that are happening right now?
-That's the only way
I can explain it
to myself and to my loved ones.
-And is there ever like --
like, how do you know
this is happening?
Do you just,
all of sudden, wake up
and realize
that time has passed?
-There's been
photographic evidence.
Now, because I love you so much
and I love everyone here
so much,
I thought about
sharing a photo with you.
-Right.
-And then I shared it
with your producer,
and we decided together
it would scare America...
-Yeah.
-...if I shared it publicly.
-The last thing we need
right now is to see you,
one of America's many
sweethearts, in a situation
that would
bring more trouble in.
-A dark place.
I was ready to share it.
I was ready to offer it,
but it's dark.
-I want to talk about the show,
but I also --
You mentioned a dog in the clip,
which makes me --
We've talked about it before,
but your dog, Tank --
How is Tank doing?
-You know, Tank is a light.
-Yeah.
-Tank is hanging in there.
Tank's doing a great job.
Tank is -- Tank's as steady
as she's ever been.
-I'm so happy to hear that,
and I want to show something
we've shown on the show before,
but I feel like it's something
everyone needs to see again,
especially because
we're just looking for anything,
any little piece of joy
that we can grab on to.
-Yeah.
-You have a video of a time, you
argue, Tank said, "I love you."
-I mean, the proof
is in the pudding.
We've been here before.
But we can revisit it.
-Let's take a look.
Here's Tank saying "I love you."
[ Tank squeals ]
-I love you. I love you.
[ Laughs ]
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-It doesn't get old, does it?
-No, it really doesn't get old.
And you keep thinking
it's not going to happen.
And I just think it speaks
to how much Tank loves you
because it doesn't look like
it's easy for her to say it.
-She's struggling.
She's suffering.
-Like, it seems like it might
take a lot of physical effort.
-She's struggling
and she's suffering
when she tries to say
"I love you."
It's not easy for her.
-I know we've also -- you've
talked about trying to get
more dialogue, more ADR,
from Tank over the years.
Have you had any success, or is
that the last thing Tank said?
-We're working on it.
-Yeah.
-She really -- I -- We've tried
and I guess we've failed.
-I mean, if you're gonna say
one thing --
-That's all I have to say.
-If you're gonna say
one thing...
-We failed.
-..."I love you" is the thing,
right?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Is Tank with you now?
-Are you ready?
-Yeah.
-Come here!
Come here, girl. Come here.
Lookit!
-Oh, my God, see this?
There is some upside to doing
Zoom interviews on talk shows.
-There is!
-Hi. Oh, my gosh, hi, Tank.
This is your moment.
This is your moment, Tank.
Tank, I just want to say
on behalf of all our viewers,
we love you.
-Tank, did you hear that?
She can't hear it.
She's trying so hard to breathe.
She doesn't really have a nose.
It takes up all of her energy
just trying to get
the air in and out.
-So that might really be one of
the reasons she's not talking
more often if she just, in
general, has trouble breathing.
-Having trouble breathing.
-Yeah.
-Oh, God.
-Thank you for the cameo, Tank.
And when we come back, we're
gonna talk more about your show.